now he's on the ground in New York City
specifically marching with protesters on
the Brooklyn Bridge a very own Lawrence
Jones or 2020 uh political correspondent
investigative reporter uh LJ we've given
you a lot easier assignments not easy
out
there good evening Sean it's been mostly
peaceful as you know that we're on the
Brooklyn Bridge right now if you can see
protesters are sitting down about a half
a mile ago uh before they got on the
bridge organizers told protesters if you
go to the left then you got to be
prepared to be arrested if you go to the
right then that's The Pedestrian way and
you'll be safe on that side but
protesters that are sitting down here
they say they're here for Brianna Taylor
and they are prepared to be arrested
right now as you can see Sean they are
sitting right in the middle of the
bridge right now uh we don't know what's
going to happen Sean but we'll stay out
here give you the latest we've been in
contact with our police sources to's see
what's going on on their side of the
story uh we'll give you the latest we'll
continue to follow with them uh for the
rest of the night
and of course Lawrence if any of them
are arrested New York has their all new
no bail policy they'll be back out on
the street and they can rejoin the
effort can't
they that's correct Sean that's part of
the new bail reform e effort from the
DA's office as well as from the attorney
general um if they are arrested tonight
they will probably make Bill all right
Lawrence Jones on the ground be safe for
Lawrence thank you and